this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
profession or just a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace
check out their awesome all in one
platform through the link in the
description below
more on them in a bit
in the entire history of the united
states there has only ever been
one unelected president a single man who
neither won a presidential election nor
was elected vice president
at the moment he reached the oval office
the only electorate gerald ford had ever
faced were the voters of michigan's 5th
district a 12-term representative and
minority speaker of the house
ford seemed destined to go down in
history as a mere footnote a man
who'd had a solid career before retiring
to a life of
golf and afternoon naps in 1973 he even
told his wife that he was
ready to call time on his career instead
fate threw a curveball that would change
american history
that october the abrupt resignation of
spyro agnew left richard nixon desperate
for a new vice president
barely had he settled on ford then nixon
himself was toppled by the watergate
scandal thrashed into the white house
ford took over a bitterly divided nation
that was tearing at the seams
his attempts to fix it would have
consequences to this very day
[Music]
as a congressman gerald ford was famous
among his colleagues for his genial
disposition for
never seeming to be phased by anything
but there was one subject that caused
ford visible discomfort
one topic he would try to avoid for the
rest of his life
his father born leslie lynch king jr in
omaha on the 14th of july 1913
ford spent the first two miserable years
of his life carrying
his hated par's name leslie king was a
mean drunk who regularly beat ford's
mother dorothy when she finally fled his
toxic grasp in 1915 for the safety of
grand rapids michigan
the wealthy leslie refused to send a
penny in child support
perhaps it's no wonder that dorothy
re-christened her little boy jerry after
a new husband
gerald rudolph ford a midwesterner to
his core gerald was a paint salesman who
believed in virtues like hard work
patriotism and loyalty he also believed
in family in 1916 he officially adopted
young jerry raising the boy as his own
he clearly made a big impression
as a teenager ford idolized his
stepfather tried to emulate him in every
way
as soon as he was old enough he legally
changed his own name to gerald ford
but the similarities with his stepdad
went beyond just his name
like gerald ford believed in loyalty to
your kin when the great depression
threatened to kill his stepdad's
business
ford worked long hours waiting tables to
help pay the bills much later he'd say
that the experience had taught him one
essential truth the harder you work the
luckier you are
i worked like hell yes it would be while
working that ford suffered one of the
nastiest shocks of his life
by now a strapping lad of 17 ford was
clearing tables one day when he saw a
customer looking at him strangely
at first the future president thought
nothing of it but then that customer
stood up
came over and said leslie i'm your
father.
that star wars moment was one of the few
events that ever threw ford off balance
he later told people he felt like this
monster was trying to intrude on his
happy family life to destroy the
relationship it forged with his stepdad
after that meeting he'd never speak to
his biological father again
still such painful moments were rare in
the life of jerry ford
by senior year he was a star football
player who'd be voted most popular in
his class
still even at this tender age he
couldn't translate being well liked
into electoral success that year he ran
for class president on the progressive
tickets and in a nice bit of
foreshadowing
he lost not that this bothered jerry at
the time awarded a football scholarship
to the university of michigan
he excelled so well on the team that
both the detroit lions and the green bay
packers nangled contracts before him but
ford could never quite
trust that his dream career might work
out instead he took a job coaching
football at yale and after three years
pestering the faculty
was allowed to enroll in law classes the
dual workload of training and studying
was crushing but
if there's one thing ford never lacked
it was work ethic
he graduated in january 1941 in the top
third of his class
back in grand rapids he opened a law
firm with an old friend and
began to flirt with republican politics
like everyone in the community ford in
1941 was a staunch isolationist
one who felt that the united states
should stay aloof from the cares of the
world
but something was about to happen that
would completely transform the young
man's perspective
setting him on the path to washington
gerald ford
was about to go to war
[Music]
on december the 7th 1941 america's
isolationists found themselves
catapulted
into a terrifying new reality images of
fire engulfing ships at pearl harbor
dominated the newspapers
in the wake of the atrocity gerald ford
enlisted in the navy because of his
background the navy assigned him a post
putting new recruits through a grueling
fitness program
screw that ford basically said i want to
go to fight
it took forever but at last after enough
pestering the navy was like
fine god damn it you go to the pacific
assigned to the uss monterey ford at
last saw the action that he craved over
the course of the war he'd earned
himself 10 battle stars
it also come within an inch of losing
his life not via a japanese bullet
but by a typhoon that almost swept him
overboard by the time ford last returned
to grand rapids in the fall of 1945 he
was changed man
the war had transformed him into an
ardent internationalist
certain that america needed to take its
place on the world stage
it had also turned his interest in
republican politics
into an obsession for the first three
years after returning to michigan ford
lived a regular middle class life
working in a law firm making money
playing golf
he even found time to woo betty ann
bloomer a former dancer that he adored
beneath this comfortable surface though
something was awakening an ambition ford
never knew he harbored ford wanted to
get into politics
at the time michigan's reliably
republican fifth district was
represented
by an ardent isolationist this bothered
ford just as it bothered plenty of other
young republicans
together they decided to primary the
incumbent it was an audacious move one
ford quietly told betty that
he thought would fail still he brought
his tireless work ethic to the task
canvassing all up and down the district
going door to door talking to any voter
who'd listen
it was a tactic that worked ford won his
primary by 10 000 votes in such a
red-leaning district that
could only mean one thing gerald ford
let's go to washington
in fall 1948 ford and betty married just
months later the pair moved to dc and
ford entered the house for the first of
12 consecutive terms
not that he'd get very far at first
ford's political progress was less like
someone riding a rocket ship to the top
and more like a
balloon lazily rising into the afternoon
sky for his first two terms the new
representative did
almost nothing of note aside from making
friends with a promising young lawmaker
from california
named richard nixon it was only in 1953
by which time his californian friend had
already risen to vice president
that ford joined a subcommittee for the
next eight years ford slowly built a
reputation based on three things
fiscal conservatism anti-communism and a
borderline insane loyalty towards nixon
even though he was only vp at this stage
dick nixon
was already living up to his nickname
forging a reputation as an unstable
vindictive sociopath yet ford defended
his old buddy unconditionally even if
his
buddy seemed to have more or less
completely forgotten that he existed
one ungrateful aside though ford was
doing pretty well
well enough that he began to nurture a
new dream to become
speaker of the house it was a hell of an
ambition starting in 1954 the house saw
a democrat winning streak that would
last clear until bill freaking clinton
was in the oval office
even before this the house had only gone
republican twice since
herbert hoover had been voted out for a
republican like ford dreaming of
becoming speaker was a little bit like
uri dreaming of
becoming america's next top model still
ford
tried his damnedest joining forces with
the gop faction that called themselves
the young turks he
managed to topple the republican old
guard after the party's dismal 1964
election
becoming minority speaker now all he
needed was one big republican win in the
house and he'd fulfill his dream of
holding the speaker's gavel sadly for
ford that win would never come
but that didn't mean his career was
destined to stall out as minority
speaker
in just nine years he would go from
historical also ran
to president of the united states and
hey if you're looking for success beyond
your wildest dreams in your next venture
whether it's
running for office or just running a
website you've got to get a website done
with squarespace now more than ever
people are getting creative with their
time they're reaching
into their pockets to start a new
business or launch a new blog the world
really is yours and squarespace is the
perfect web tool to help you fashion it
into whatever you like it's the platform
to use when you're ready to get started
on that next web project that you've
been thinking about
are you looking to get in and out
quickly without thinking too much about
what your website should look like
bam use one of their quick and beautiful
templates to make a website that's fresh
and for you
or maybe you're more of a hands-on
person you've got lots of opinions and
ideas about exactly what your site
should look like
well squarespace gives you all of the
customization options that you could
ever want with no updates no patches no
technical bs to worry about
once you're done setting up your website
tinkering with the design if you're so
inclined there's so many extra features
that squarespace provides so that your
website can thrive
email campaigns patronage portals social
integrations member-only areas analytics
commercial options 24 7 support
so much stuff all in one place so when
you're ready to get started on that next
project of yours big
or small if it involves a website it's
got to be with squarespace
right now you can go to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch your site go to
squarespace.com forward slash
biographics
to take 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain
and let's get back to ford
so here it is at last the crazy part the
part that would have seemed like
fiction to ford's colleagues back in
1964.
the part where ford becomes president
not by running in an election or even by
getting on the ticket as
vp for a president doomed to die no ford
was destined to become president
through sheer dumb luck the 970s dawned
with ford seemingly having passed his
career high watermark
in 1968 it watched as house republicans
came within an inch of a majority
only to just fall short still he'd
returned to congress full of hope his
old california buddy was now president
and he felt sure nixon would work
closely with
him on passing legislation in reality
nixon's team thought ford was a clown of
the highest order
in private they agreed with lyndon
johnson's withering assessment that
jerry ford is so dumb that he can't fart
and chew
gum at the same time as nixon was
re-elected in 1972 ford privately began
to admit to betty that he was getting
worn out
that being minority leader wasn't
cutting it anymore he promised her he'd
take
just one more shot at the speaker's
gavel in the 1974 midterms
and if that failed well he would bow to
politics knowing that he'd tried his
best
in the end though ford would never
compete in the midterms that's because
the biggest scandal of the 20th century
was about to blow through washington
like a sleazy hurricane back in 1972
people connected to nixon's campaign
to re-elect the president pleasingly
abbreviated to creep
were caught burglarizing the democratic
national committee's officers in the
watergate building days after the story
broke
ford sought out nixon's advisers to ask
if the president was involved they told
him
no presumably while crossing their
fingers super hard behind their backs
because nixon was already up to his neck
in watergate and it wasn't the only
scandal rocking his administration
on the 10th of october 1973 vice
president spyro agnew appeared in court
to answer corruption charges before
giving testimony
he resigned his post that evening ford
was at home
trying to unwind after a stressful day
just as he was thinking about heading to
bed he got a call
a white house aide was on the other end
hal the aide asked would ford feel about
becoming vice president
i suspect if i was asked ford replied
characteristically calm
i would accept it knowing what we do
today the phone call can seem inevitable
just one more step on the 38th
president's path to office
but the reality is that it only happened
due to a kaleidoscope of coincidences
the first of these is that nixon needed
a new vice president at all just a
decade earlier the u.s had
been without a veep for over a year
after johnson took over from kennedy
for ages there had been no mechanism to
actually replace a fallen vp
it had only been since 1967 that the
25th amendment allowed presidents to
nominate a new veep in emergencies ford
was the first person ever nominated in
this way the second factor
was the lack of other candidates
although nixon had presented a list he
was told that none would be confirmed by
the democratic congress the genial ford
was just about the only republican who
would a want the job and b
survived the nomination process bird and
finally
there was watergate itself there's
evidence nixon could see impeachment
coming and wanted to make sure the
alternative was even worse than
letting him stay in office by offering a
choice between removing him from power
and getting president khan phantom shoe
or
just allowing nixon to stay on tricky
dick was banking on congress
choosing the devil they knew on december
6 1973 gerald ford became vice president
of the united states
he told betty the post would be a nice
conclusion to his career
in his first speech he indicated he
would simply serve out the rest of
agnew's term
then leave alongside nixon in january of
1977 but that wasn't how history was
going to roll
in less than a year nixon would be gone
and ford would be making history
our long national nightmare
is over before vp ford had even been
confirmed the wheels
were coming off the nixon administration
the saturday night massacre on october
20th 1973 saw nixon fire the special
prosecutor investigating watergate
setting off the mother of all storms in
d.c
by the summer of 1974 the supreme court
was ordering him to turn over the tapes
he'd recorded of private conversations
related to the scandal
it was closing time on the nixon
presidency yet even now ford didn't seem
to grasp the enormity of what was
happening
as solid and reliable as ever the new vp
simply continued to defend his old
friend even as the red flags transformed
into urgent semaphore screaming
do not trust this dude it was only when
the audio transcript showing nixon's
involvement in the watergate cover-up
was released
the ford finally heeded them on august 6
1974 nixon called cabinet meeting to
declare
that he'd never resign if helen ford
took his old pal in the eye and tell him
the cabinet could no longer defend him
by now it's almost certain ford had
realized that he was going to be
president there was no way
nixon could remain in power until
january 77.
but even ford didn't realize how soon
tricky dick would be gone
on august 8th nixon abruptly went on tv
to announce his resignation effective
noon the next day
it was all the warning ford got to
prepare himself for the presidency the
very next day richard nixon clambered
into a helicopter
and flew off into ignominy as he
vanished over the horizon the accidental
vice president took the oath of office
and became the accidental president
addressing the cameras ford still
looking like he couldn't quite believe
what was happening declared
my fellow americans our long
national nightmare is over
our constitution works our great
republic is a government of laws and not
of men here
the people rule it was a nice sentiment
well expressed
in response ford's approval rating
soared it would be the only time america
ever fully supported
its new leader one month later on
september the 8th president ford issued
perhaps the most infamous pardon in u.s
history
absolving nixon of any crimes he may
have committed ford intended to draw a
line under watergate to
let the nation move on with the healing
instead
he pressed the self-destruct button on
his own presidency in the media ford was
accused of making a corrupt bargain with
nixon
he was called testify before a house
committee his poll numbers crated
it was the sharpest drop in public
opinion since polling began
less than a month into his first term
gerald ford had already torpedoed any
chance he had at re-election remember
donald trump once saying that
he could shoot someone in the middle of
fifth avenue and still not lose any
votes
well the opposite was now true for ford
he could be caught on film running into
a burning orphanage to save a basket of
puppies
and america would still treat him like
the guy who farted at a funeral
but while ford was toast there was still
another two years until americans could
deliver their verdict at the ballot box
two years in which ford would stumble on
wounded hemorrhaging support
trying to make his mark in the face of a
hostile congress as we're about to see
it was not going to be a pretty sight
[Music]
the presidency ford inherited was the
ultimate poison chalice
inflation unemployment was soaring oil
prices were high
there were riots in big cities nyc was
about to go bust and
america was just months away from
comprehensively losing the vietnam war
but
even given the mess nixon left him it'd
be hard to say
jerry ford rose to the challenge take
the economic nightmare known as
stagflation in the fight against
inflation and unemployment ford's
advisers initially convinced him to
tackle inflation
in fall of 1974 the white house printed
12 million badges bearing the acronym
win for whip inflation now part of a
drive to
hike taxes and slash government spending
but barely had the first 100 000 badges
been distributed
then ford discovered the u.s was in
recession and immediately pulled a
massive u-turn by instead cutting taxes
the whiplash was jarring and became even
more
so when the democrat-controlled congress
forced through government spending
increases but while the economy would
eventually improve under ford
it never really felt like it in spring
of 1975 for example
new york city went bust although the
gop's moderate wing urged ford to bail
out the nation's largest city
the fiscally conservative forward just
couldn't bring himself to do it
the result the infamous newspaper
headline ford to city
dropped dead eventually after months of
wrangling ford did agree to release
federal funds but
this was just as bad having alienated
moderate republicans before now he
severely pissed off the conservative
wing by
caving to public pressure then there was
bussing
lost in the bombshell of nixon's
resignation had been the order of a
boston judge to use bussing to
desegregate the city's schools
this had led to riots black kids had
been surrounded spat on a called racial
slurs one white kid had been stabbed
sadly ford once again found himself
falling into the crack between his
party's two wings
having been to an integrated high school
fault was all in favor but
as a small government conservative he
couldn't abide a judge
forcing integration to happen the result
was a flip-flopping on the issue that
again angered everyone all while boston
burned the tragedy of ford's character
is that what appeared to be
indecisiveness actually came from a core
set of beliefs deep within his soul
at heart ford was still a typical
midwesterner he believed in hard work
and
neighborliness in a decent world where
people would choose to be decent of
their own accord without the government
needing to step
in these are not bad values to hold but
at a time when left and right were both
diverging
they simply didn't match the mood maybe
if ford could have positioned himself
firmly in either camp
he would have won another term maybe he
could have succeeded as a rockefeller
moderate or
a reagan before bregen alas before it
couldn't be either of those things in
his first days in office
ford had tried to reach across the aisle
offering the post of national security
adviser to a conservative democrat
if nothing else it would have been
interesting a sign of a leader taking
his party in a new direction but ford
wasn't a natural leader he wavered at
the last second then
withdrew the offer just as he wavered
expelling members of nixon's cabinet
there's a reason jerry ford only became
president by accident
a reason he never desired the oval
office perhaps deep down he simply
knew that he wouldn't be very good at it
[Music]
despite usually showing up in the lower
half of presidential rankings gerald
ford's tenure wasn't a complete car
crash
he wasn't corrupt he didn't start a
civil war or in sight insurrection
occasionally he even managed to pull out
a win the fall of saigon in april 1975
was an epic humiliation for the united
states one
ford couldn't have stopped but he was
able to shape the nation's response to
that humiliation and he managed to do so
with a humanitarian touch championing a
bill that allowed special status to
those fleeing communist regimes in
vietnam lao and cambodia
ford helped get 130 000 refugees quickly
resettled
in the usa it was a gesture that won him
no friends
on his party's right but it did send a
very clear signal
under jerry ford america would no longer
abandon those who'd helped her a
slightly more gung-ho pr win came a
month later
after kaima rouge forces captured the
u.s vessel maegers ford ordered a
commando team to liberate the ship
although 40 americans died in the fire
fight the vessel was secured
in the wake ford saw his poll numbers
saw still they weren't good enough to
guarantee re-election
and now he'd had a taste of the
presidency ford no longer wanted to just
step down
in january 77. so he set out on a
cross-country tour to convince voters
to give him a second term instead it
almost got him killed
within the space of 17 days in september
ford narrowly survived two assassination
attempts the first was at the hands of
immense and cult member lynette squeaky
from who
pointed a pistol at ford but was tackled
by the secret service
the second call was closer a mentally
unstable accountant sarah jane moore
managed to get off a shot at the
president before a bystander disarmed
her yet ford managed to shake off these
two near-misses with comparative ease
far harder to shake off was the
electorate's image of him as a total
buffoon
this was the early era of saturday night
live when its sketches set the tone for
the national conversation
every week chevy chase was playing
forward as a graceless klutz who
blew his nose with his tie fell over
everything and couldn't say a straight
sentence
however unfair it was an image of ford
that stuck in everyone's mind
so when a charismatic conservative
former film star announced that he was
going to run against the president
in the republican primaries it was clear
ford was going to be fighting an uphill
battle
ronald reagan's 1976 primary campaign
was almost good enough to unseat the
38th president
in a sign of how the times were changing
his message resonated so much with the
gop's right that
ford barely scraped his party's
nomination but the real danger in 76
wasn't from the reagan right but
from a one-term governor and former
peanut farmer on the left
jimmy carter was a political novice with
low name recognition but post-watergate
that outsider status helped him win
voter's trust as the man who'd pardoned
nixon
how could ford ever compete on the 2nd
of november 1976 gerald ford faced the
national electorate for the first time
in his life
while he outperformed his polls it
wasn't enough to net him a second term
geraldford departed the white house in
january 1977
convinced this wasn't the end convinced
he'd run again in 1980 and become
president
with a real mandate this time but by now
his party was desperate for change
ford didn't even compete against reagan
in the 1980 primaries nonetheless
reagan offered him the vp slot on his
ticket a graceful olive branch
for his former rival but having been
president once ford could
not go back to being just the vp again
in the wake of reagan's blowout victory
ford faded from public imagination a
relic of a bygone more complicated time
he had a pleasant retirement playing
golf and giving speeches but turning
down reagan's vp pick
was the last time he made any mark on
history jerry ford died on
december 26 2006 at the age of 93.
he was buried in his beloved grand
rapids if ford reflected on his legacy
in his last few days
it's curious to wonder what he felt to
his credit most today believe pardoning
nixon was the right move
helping to draw a line under a sordid
episode in us history ford's own
character too helped restore some
dignity to a white house that had been
badly tarnished
but these are mostly abstract
achievements tiny stars amid a glowing
constellation of
indifference yeah maybe that's the wrong
way to look at things
gerald ford may have left a lot to be
desired as a president but
it's worth remembering that the post is
one he never sought
one he fell into by accident like his
snl caricature plunging headfirst off a
stage
for a former house minority speaker who
should have faded into comfortable
obscurity
the fact that we're talking about him at
all is kind of an achievement
the fluke that made ford presidents may
have been a one-off born of
a strange era in american politics but
it does mean
that history will now always remember
jerry ford
the friendly hardworking boy from
michigan who grew up to briefly lead the
free world
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe also please do check out
our friends
squarespace there's a link below and
thank you for watching